Her low freak bitches and before that,
you know,
you just go back a few more
people and they were grunting.
Yeah. I mean they, they,
they hadn't even figured out how to write
things down. They, you know, or even,
you know,
what's,
what's even crazier to think about is
how we've taken airplanes and perfected
that. And the last 50 years, you know,
before that it was, you know, you didn't,
you couldn't just get on an airplane and
be anywhere in the world in 24 hours.
Oh yeah.
It's a total units.
Parents 1903 you want to hear the
craziest fucking statistics. Emer okay.
Between the time that plane was invented,
the,
between the invention of the airplane and
someone dropping an atomic bomb out of
the airplane, it was less than
50 years. Yeah. That's crazy.
What we do to each other.
I know
it was like somewhere like 44
years or something like that.
Between the invention of the
airplane by the Wright brothers,
the first flight and then a bomb
dropping on Hiroshima. Yeah.
And then now there's fast and
furious eight and they got bombs
segues plug there. It was good.
Well you should go publicist,
just totally unrelated. Just thought of
that. How many of those have you done? No,
this is the first one that I've
done. This is the first one. Yeah,
this is the eighth. This
will be the eighth one. And
they're going to do 10 right?
So they're doing a back to back
because I went there, done. I didn't,
that's the plan. Uh, you know
I'm not, I'm not a, you know,
I'm sure van and vin diesel and
the producers have, you know, the,
the plan set. But I mean
that's the whispers. I hear
that we do a couple more. Um,
I think 10 would be cool. He made it this
far. Might as well go to 10 right now.
Can you tell us, does your character
survive? Can you give us a spoiler alert?
I saw the movie,
you can tell us that you're not obvious
if you didn't have to sign anything.
It was, it was good last night. I
mean Scott had a big role. I was,
it was cool cause I didn't know, you know,
you never know. Like didn't, didn't ask,
didn't anything. But yeah, he's all over
it the whole time. So it was cool. He did.
He got a job.
Let's just say it's a good one then
everyone will like it or you also car God.
Do you like muscle cross? I'm a
classic car guy. Um, I like classics.
I love the old sixties.
A Ferrari between a Ferrari and
for that whole rivalry back then.
So the GTS exactly. Yeah,
exactly. I'm actually getting, uh,
getting the opportunity to purchase
uh, one of the new GTS, uh,
coming out in 2017. Really do
that thing looks insane. Insane.
And they're making only a hundred
this year. Punch our cunts a hundred.
I was so excited about it.
Why would you make 107 billion people?
You didn't make a hundred cars,
asshole collectibles. So I mean,
how much they charge for those for 100
bucks. Rough for a hundred of them are,
I mean, I think the price
is about three, three 50,
$350,000. It's a collective.
Sure. This fucking thing. It's,
it's a beast. Look at that thing.
Know it's the new one. Sanity.
Yeah.
Configurator can can fit.
Why are they letting you configure
it if you can't even fucking buy it?
Just a bunch of teases forward. What
are you doing that, first of all,
that doesn't even look like a Ford.
I mean that looks,
that looks like a Ford on planet Mars.
It's pretty much changing the code
that lets you know, like a Ferrari.
Jamie's can crap. It looks better than
a Ferrari. I think. You know, that's,
that's bad ass car.
Let me see the,
see if she got some other angles on it.
Is there any other angles? Look at that.
Pretty like the hood. Oh
my gosh. Oh. Cammo on that
Ridge reaper option. Look
at that. Fucking God.
Oh my God. What a beast. I think
I might get one to actually, wow.
Go for it, dude. Go for it. Of just
my ram, my whole life of salary,
but that's
$350,000 but meanwhile,
the way they're making cars today,
that thing's got to be insane there.
But that'll be like a piece of art
that that will be, you know, like the,
the GTE knowing the older gts that have
gone up in value because they just don't,
it's hard to say that. What about new
cars though? So much plastic and stuff.
They just don't seem to, people
don't want them, you know,
like if you get up 1960s car,
it's worth a shit load of money today.
But in the 1990s client worth shit.
You know what I mean?
It's like there's no classics from 1990
it was a couple of porches, like nine,
nine six fours from the nineties or
nine nine three is the last of the air
cooled cars. They're still worth
some money there. They're classics.
But that's kind of it. Like maybe a
few classic Ferrari's from that day,
but like a Camaro from 1990 yeah.
Push that thing off a cliff
and shoot at it while
it's on its way down. Hey,
don't let your girl drive that car. Oh,
she got issues. We were saying before,
she ain't,
she crashes things a little bit.
History of a long history. Let's
leave it at that. Hey listen,
people can't be great at everything.
You know. That's true. Yeah.
Good. Yeah. So now they just
pointed to the side. And
what about like fight scenes?
Do you have to do fight
scenes? Like especially you
have martial arts background,
should have you do scenes.
Yeah, I didn't do the,
there wasn't a terrible amount of, uh, a
fight slammed, slammed against the wall.
I could see I get slapped around a little
bit in this one, but a sure, you know,
in, in other films, I love doing that
stuff. That's the fun stuff. Especially,
you know, cause cause you get to
hang with those, the, you know,
some of the coolest guys on sets, all
the, all the stunt guys, you know,
they're all, you know,
likeminded people, all, you know,
martial art background guys.
Um, and so you're just choreographing
all day working that out.
And then you get on set and you're
doing it or you're, you're, you're,
you're doing it with them because
they might be planning the, you know,
villa number seven or something,
you know, something. So then you're,
you've already sort of got a
shorthand with them and your that's,
that's the fun stuff.
That's cool.
It's way better than dealing with
like a difficult actor or something.
Do you ever do that? Yeah.
Who's the worst? Oh, come on.
Make it make their name or something
else. Doesn't make their name. Ryan,
let's, you know, uh, you'll,
you'll get me in trouble like
guys. Oh, that's right. Oh yeah.
That's why here I thought
it was torpedoes, but nope.
Might just be lips and loose
lips yet in the scene, uh,
the rock picks him up, like in slams and
holds them against the wall and the dam.
My royal was that real.
It's real.
It's real with some assistance.
There's some movie magic,
but he's, he's a big guy.
I mean, it's real. You would have dropped
him and choked him out. Dot. Dude.
So jacked. He took a photo of him after
workout the other day and I'm like, yeah,
he's huge.
So discipline to 4:00 AM like,
man does he is when you're on set with
him, was he just always doing that?
Like what's his deal? He's just
extremely disciplined guy. Um, you know,
I got a lot of respect
for him. He's uh, he's,
he knows what he wants and he is going
to get it. Like he's not there is no, no,
he is taking it down.
He's making movie after movie after movie.
He's going to go do it. He's uh,
you know, he eats religiously.
He's got these meals are
towns, you know, which is,
I love doing a meal prep
stuff cause it's great.
Makes his life one less thing
to think about. Right. Um,
but he's very religious with it.
Look at that piece of meat. He's more
jack now than he's ever been in his life.
I think he's 44, 44 46 or something. Yeah.
And just crazy reject. Yeah.
Continuing to get more and more.
Jack still still putting in the work.
He's not done getting jacked. He's,
he's keeping pumping it. He's
keeping it going. It's just a,
when you see his schedule and his
workload and then there's always some new
projects is doing all this doing
a TV show and he's doing it. No,
fuck does he have time?
And he's hosting this award show and
he's like doing something for the troops
and then he's doing this movie and
finishing up that movie. He's like,
how I tell you the travel is what
kills me. I know you probably,
you've been in show business
for all longer than all of
us, you know. Um, and uh,
the travel is what kills you, right? He's
not the fate of the furious April 14th.
That's when it comes out this Friday or
vin diesel and the rocket odds in this
photo, I can't tell. It seems
like there was, hey, that piece,
that patients that I read or was
that real? Yeah. And it's all,
it's all just don't believe it.
Don't put anything on the Internet.
Some real issues to two alphas collided
on the set and Mindy's wouldn't take off
the sunglasses even at night.
It was so strange.
Fucking dope cars though, man,
dude. So he took off his necklace.
I pay attention to that. What kind of
cars they have in this episode. Oh,
that's not a charger with
the flared fenders. Yeah.
You got like sort of
supercharge their charge.
I that sucker was on display somewhere,
right?
That charger isn't on display somewhere.
It might've been. I mean it's,
it's one of the hero cars in the
phone. Fucking insane car. Oh my God.
That's pretty sexy, right? Yeah. Those,
those American cars from the late
sixties early seventies so you just,
you just can't get anything like
that sexy. Yeah. God amazing. Yeah.
That one's got a custom grill to look
at that grill on that soccer. Whoa.
No Ram Truck, Huh? No, no.
Cam's a fan of the ram trucks.
It's okay. I liked drugs.
Sex sells. Yeah, I do too.
But they just don't, there's
something about, you know,
you can't get a ram truck
with supercharger popping
out of the hood like that.
Oh sure. Big whole blowing look, they're
fighting. Oh No, that's Jason Day then.
Nevermind. Oh Jason say those
fighting who rock something. That's,
I don't think that's the rock. The rocket
was brown. Well, he's the peritoneum.
Xbox. He's got baby oil on
and Jason stayed on. I would,
I would help to pull them
aside and go, hey Ron. Yeah,
look at me. Look at me. Run.
Run the other way. But he,
he's fight, right? Yeah.
He's got a martial arts background for
sure. Yeah. Yeah. That was Jason's Day.
Them can fight for sure, but, uh, still
run. Hey, look at that rocks. Fucking,
we'll get that answer. Pastor
Jesus. Cool features on that guy.
Young Clint Eastwood. You, hey, how
dare you do that? High cheek bones.
A handsome fella.
I don't understand why he's so upset.
Angry out of the Hollywood guys are angry.
I don't know why.
[inaudible]
yeah.